but i didn't think i could do it but i
did it
i know
one small step for dawn one giant eep
for friend kind what are you calling a
giant oh yeah that didn't come out right
but we made it to the top
we did it
i guess that means i got my girl back
thanks for all the help you know what
you never lost your girl you've always
had it just like me what are you talking
about i was terrified i'll let you in on
another little secret i get scared too
what yeah that's right storms barracudas
even volcanoes but i don't let it stop
me and neither did you that's true ger
whoa that's huge this is a day to
remember
i need a memento
how about this weird rock
that's not a rock that's a tooth a
really big tooth
[Music]
i knew grant's story was too short
yeah she forgot the part about the
mountain being alive this is on my
scared list
mine too
but i've got ger there's even a fire in
my belly or it's the vine squeezing me
either way this mountain is going down
that's right other girl because grant is
here to save you my name is dawn yeah
and john is gonna save us because she's
all good
[Music]
not bad but if she can save you why did
i have to come all the way up here
not liking the look of those vines
it's nothing a little mountain mayhem
can't fix
yeah let's go this hill so this part is
all me right it's okay grant we got this
seriously last time i rush out to save
you two from a living mountain
[Music]
how do we get past it oh why are you
asking me it's his other girl's show er
where'd she go don hold up she's not
here dawn
needless grandma
[Applause]
thanks for saving us i didn't save you
but you saved oh yeah but i did save you
thanks for reminding me that i could
you're welcome and thanks for doing my
job back there don
hey you remember my name
don't get cocky girl
you